second of all for the category of uh
promising research direction for future
potential goes to
miss ayushi notra she has completed her
master's in bioinformatics honors and
her topic was identification of critical
genes associated with intra hepatic
polyneurocarcinoma weight gene for
expression network analysis
hi i
am
around can you please turn on your
camera and also
your mind come on
yes hello
um
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank pine biotech and omix logic for
giving me this opportunity to present my
research work and get it reviewed by
judges from
from all around the globe and i will i
would also like to thank the judges for
selecting my project as the most
promising research direction for future
potential
in this project i tried to correlate the
genes associated with this cancer with
the tumor micro environment and as we
know that the tumor microenvironment
plays a very critical role in the cancer
progression development in metastasis so
it was a great area to work on thank you
and thank you and uh congratulations
that's a wonderful award so
where will you go next what is what are
your plans next
well i'm pretty much very interested in
studying how a particular disease occurs
in the body at the transcriptomics level
so i would want to carry on my research
further by on
this particular topic only where i study
diseases and how that particular disease
is caused and the underlying genes
responsible for the
disease occurrence in the body
do you have a recommendation to others
for trying to work on their own projects
or trying to win
yes
i would like to recommend everybody that
do a lot of like literature review
because that enables you to
have a particular research interest um
ignited inside of you so a literature
review is passed and so that you can you
know find your particular interest in a
particular research domain because there
are n number of things that you can do
using bioinformatics so do um the
literature review and find your
particular interest and then work on it
fascinating thank you so much and again
congratulations sunderly